[Applause]
and the spirit award for best new
scripted series goes to
reservation
[Music]
tyco
dogs
first nomination and first win
reservation dogs features all indigenous
writers and directors along with an
almost entirely indigenous cast and
production team and the show was shot
entirely in the state of oklahoma
reservation dogs
[Music]
[Applause]
hello
thank you so much um
to the independence i was i've been here
before never won an award so it's really
exciting um
you know we're on tonga land the
original people of this land
and i want to honor them
um
it's really beautiful to be a part of
this community barry raphael i mean like
legends right like people i love all of
you and i love being a part of this
community
and
we don't want to hand out we just want
an opportunity
to tell our stories that's all
um
created this show with my brother taiko
ytti and and uh
you know and there's nothing that gives
me more pleasure than creating something
with my friend
we've traveled through new zealand and
his weird little fringe car that had
hydraulics
uh slept in the same hotel together told
stories about home and that's why we
made this show because we told stories
about home and they were all funny and
there was nothing on tv that was funny
that had natives in it and we wanted to
show you how funny we are and
fx thank thank you fx
to kate nick samantha our producer
garrett bosh
dean everybody that helped us do that
because
um
they they no one knew i mean no one knew
we were funny and and and they took a
chance and they were like all right
we're gonna believe you
i think you're funny in the room you're
funny so maybe the show will be funny
and i and i want to shout out to this
cast because
um
i mean like
they came to oklahoma and they they
poured their heart and soul in this
because they could see
that we were changing something and they
could see that we were showing who we
are as native people
and
uh
there's no better cast in the world than
this and i i thank them so much for
bleeding their hearts out every day to
tell this story
i thank everyone back home in oklahoma
you're the reason why i do this my
friends my family
thank you so much thanks so much
you